Film Courage: Choice, did you grow up in New York? Choice Skinner, actor/instructor: Yeah...
I was born and raised Brooklyn, New York
and I went to high school there, went to
elementary school there, went to junior
high school. Yeah and I always say
that I'm a project kid. I don't have any
problem saying that. You know that's
something that uh sometimes people have
a little shame with but I don't because
I wouldn't be who I am if I didn't have
those experiences. I grew up not too far
away from Mike Tyson you know in New
York. We have what's called blocks. And a
block is maybe a couple of yards
depending on where you stay. I was in
East New York (Brooklyn).
I grew up across the street from
Jefferson High School. So Mike Tyson
stayed in the opposite direction and
it's a funny story about that Mike Tyson.
He has some cousins and one day I had some
sneakers that was given to me some
Converse All Star we used to call them
(leather, black on white, upper ankle tops).
And so "high tops" they called me and my
brother he was always the guy around
the neighborhood and everybody knew who...
was like "you don't mess with this family"
because of him. Well anyway I got these
high tops in school and by being on the
honor roll and they were like eight
these guys are gonna take your sneakers
I don't like what I just got him like
who's gonna take my sneakers and
apparently they were like kind of play
cousins of Mike Tyson and so I was
terrified throughout the whole class
people were telling me man I'm gonna
take your sneakers what are you gonna do
I gotta figure out something so end of
class the bell rings and I'm saying oh
my god I got to go out here and we get
beat up in front of everybody and these
guys are gonna take my shoes my sneakers
off of my heat so me being the smart
person that I was at that age I said
okay I don't want to do that I'm gonna
go to the other direction so there was a
teacher who she was leaving and I said
listen can I can I leave with you you
mind if I walk out this way we went out
the back way as I walk out the back way
I can look down the street on the corner
and I could see that these guys were
waiting so I did the right thing and I
home as I get to the stoop my brother
standing here he said why you sweating
what's going on and I'm like these guys
are gonna take my sneakers there he goes
who show me and so I go and I point to
them and he goes all right you go home
he beats these guys up yeah my brother
my brother he was an amazing being back
then in those days so anyway my point is
the reason why I'm saying that is
growing up in Brooklyn it was tough
it wasn't easy I got mugged it was it
was tough it was tough back in the 80s
it wasn't easy but it helped me to get
into the martial arts which is something
that's helped me in my life tremendously
and it helped me to know a lot about
myself so you know I'm a smart guy I
mean you can't pull the wool over my
eyes and you can't sell me the Brooklyn
Bridge it's not gonna happen anytime
soon
so yeah growing up in New York but there
was fun things in New York as well I
mean it was great growing up in the 80s
I mean come on you had the best music
you know and he had some of the best
experiences ever but uh I learned a lot
about who I was and what I was going to
become by growing up in New York. Film Courage: One of
my favorite sort of sayings is "owning
your own story." And I heard that one time when
I was looking at some comments on an
article and someone talked about that
and I was like "Wow?" And it's about
accepting where you're from and who you
are and being okay with that. I think a
lot of people do want to put on airs
when they come to LA because their shame
or whatever I can say I felt that yeah
so when did you decide you know what I'm
gonna own my own story and I'm okay with
me I'll tell you this you know when I
when I first came out to LA was for
music I was a music producer for an R&B
artist double platinum artists on RCA
Records and one of the things that I've
learned you know I was fortunate to have
a mom who even though she was raising
five young boys she was strong she went
back to college she went got a GED and
went to college at a later age and she
always took care of us and she always
made sure we have we needed when I moved
to LA it was a thing of okay wait a
minute I've survived New York Brooklyn
and why would I have any
shame and being from where I was at in
the projects to knowing that there's
things that I can use that I learned as
a child here in LA so that whole thing
in New York they call it the rat race
being able to pound the pavement being
able to be a go-getter and being real
that fit in well for me when I moved to
LA so I didn't have a problem you know
letting people know that I was from the
project's I tell you this it's a funny
story when I went into a once I got into
acting I got out of music and I got into
acting and I went in for an audition and
it was for the part of a thug and so I
go in it's it's the audition room and
I'm sitting in a lobby and all these
guys sitting up there with tattoos and
stuffing it mean mugging and everything
and I don't look anything like a thug I
couldn't begin to do anything to make
myself look like a thug no earrings or
anything like that no piercings no
tattoos
so I'm saying oh man how am I gonna go
in here and get this audition like this
is like you know the one thing that I
learned growing up was watching other
people I didn't know I was an actor
until I became an actor and so I had a
lot in my data bank and so I go into the
room and I go into the room in character
so the casting directors like oh so um
hi choice and she goes to shake my hand
and I'll shake hands I saw I'm playing
the thug persona I booked the role I
knew I got it when I left out of here
because they were so scared then I go
hey I'm just that was me in character hi
how you doing I'm sorry shake your hand
before but that was me a character I was
just being like the guys from the
neighborhood when I grew up so that
helped me tremendously any piece of
wisdom for someone that isn't okay with
where they're from they could be from a
cul-de-sac in in a neighborhood that I
would have loved to have grown up in but
didn't they could have been from
wherever but sometimes people aren't
okay with where they're from for
whatever reason any advice to them on
that your circumstances and what you've
been through sometimes have yet to
revealed why they are important in your
life so in essence what I'm saying is
this
the circumstance doesn't make you the
circumstance prepares you for the
situation that you're gonna go through
so in essence everything that I went
through all the muggings and stuff like
that once I got into martial arts and
then once I became an actor I was able
to use so many other things and so
there's no shame in what you've been
through the only shame is not telling
anyone about it because your
circumstance in your situation is there
so that way you can probably help
someone else in the future you would be
surprised like just me talking about
being a project kid sometimes I go and I
speak at high schools or I'm on a panel
and I'll tell people this and they're
like really I would have never thought I
thought you might have been to college
and you grew up in a suburb and I'm like
no I chose to speak well because that's
what I wanted to be perceived as that's
a person who could speak well and so for
me it's a thing of the shame of hiding
something comes from not realizing that
there's power in that there's power and
being different there's power and then
coming from a place of of adversity who
wouldn't who wouldn't be able to say hey
I've been through this and I'm still
here we're strong from that and so they
embrace it embrace it because there's so
many people whose lives you're gonna
touch and I've learned that by being Who
I am and by being honest about the stuff
that I've been through I enjoy it and I
think that anybody that doesn't want to
explain a you know explain where they've
come from or what they've been through
is there they're not ready to receive
the true blessing which is touching
others
you